- [Instructor] Let's
say that X is a function
of the parameter T and
it's equal to cosine of T
and Y is also defined as a function of T
and it's equal to sin of T
and we wanna find the arc length
of the curve traced out,
so length of curve
from T is equal to zero
to T is equal to pi over two.
So, pause this video and
see if you can work that out
based on formulas that we
have seen in other videos.
Alright, so first, I'm
gonna look at the formula
and then we're gonna visualize it
and appreciate why what
we got from the formula
actually makes sense.
So, the formula tells us that arc length
of a parametric curve,
arc length is equal to the integral
from our starting point of our parameter,
T equals A to our ending
point of our parameter,
T equals B of the square
root of the derivative
of X with respect to T squared
plus the derivative of Y with
respect to T squared DT, DT.
This could also be
rewritten as this is equal
to the integral from A to B
of the square root of DX/DT squared
plus DY/DT squared DT
but either way we can now
apply it in this context.
What is DX/DT?
So, DX/DT is equal to
the derivative of cosine
of T is equal to negative sin of T,
negative sin of T
and what is DY/DT?
The derivative of Y with respect to T.
The derivative of sin of T
is cosine of T, cosine of T.
So, our arc length up
here is going to be equal
to the integral from T is equal to zero
to pi over two, that's what we care about,
our parameter's going from zero
to pi over two of the square root
of the derivative of X
with respect to T squared.
That's a negative sin of T squared,
well, if you square it the
negative's gonna go away,
we're gonna have negative
sin times negative sin
is positive sin squared,
so I could write this as sin squared of T
and then DY/DT squared,
that's just cosine squared T,
plus cosine squared T
and then we have our DT out here.
Now lucky for us, sin
squared plus cosine squared
of some variable is always
going to be equal to one.
So, that's one of our most
basic trig identities,
comes straight out of the
unit circle definition
of sin and cosine
and so, we have the square root of one,
the principle root of one
which is just going to be one,
so everything here has just simplified
to the integral from
zero to pi over two DT.
Well, this is going to be equal to,
so you could view it, this is a one here,
the antiderivative of
one with respect to T
is just gonna be T
and we're gonna evaluate
that from pi over two.
We're gonna evaluate that at pi over two
and then subtract.
It evaluated at zero,
so this is gonna be equal to pi over two
minus zero,
that's going to be equal to pi over two.
Now let's think about why
that actually does make sense.
Let's plot this curve.
So, that is my Y axis
and this is my X axis
right over here.
When T is equal to zero,
you have X of zero is cosine of zero,
X is equal to one,
and Y, sin of zero is just zero,
so Y is equal to zero,
so we're at this point right here
at T is equal to zero
and then as T increases up to pi over two,
we trace out the top right corner
of the unit circle
and we end up right over here
when T is equal to pi over two.
You could view T in this case
as some type of an angle in radians.
And so, the arc length
is really just the length
of quarter of a quarter of a unit circle.
Well, we know what the circumference
of a circle is, it is two pi R.
In the unit circle
case, the radius is one,
so the circumference of the
entire circle is two pie.
One fourth of that is
going to be pi over two.
So, it's nice when we this fancy thing
that we feel good about it in calculus
is consistent with what we
first learned in basic geometry.